there Steve Kaufman here today I'd like
to sort of start a dialogue with you out
there on of course my favorite subject
language learning and you know my
experience with cheque has really
brought home to me the fact that my
approach to language learning is upside
down in that it's the reverse of what's
normally done and and I happen to think
it's a good way to learn so I'm gonna
talk a bit about upside-down language
learning and and get some reaction from
you another term for it could be
holistic language learning I think it's
fair to say that in the conventional
language learning scenario people want
to try to learn first of all the basics
learn some of the fundamentals learn you
know perhaps in greetings they want to
try and say some things in the language
to sort of demonstrate to themselves
that they're making some progress
they'll typically find a teacher the
teacher then is supposed to know these
fundamentals so that the teacher can
impart these fundamentals to the student
typically language schools are looking
for teachers with accreditation because
they want to make sure that they can
correct any mistakes the student could
make because that's considered so very
important to correct these mistakes and
if you just have a native speaker who
may not know what the correct term is or
the correct form of a word is or may not
know how to explain why something is
used if that's gonna make it more
difficult for the learner to acquire the
basics of the language and so forth so
it's it's kind of like the building
block approach it's starting with the
fundamentals making sure you have the
fundamentals and if you then have the
fundamentals at a later stage you'll be
able to enjoy so many things in the
language you'll be able to read and and
talk to people and so forth if you have
the fundamentals down my approach is the
reverse if I were to design
a language course and I'm thinking of
doing this now for cheque and that is to
say that six months from now I would
like to have someone very good a good
teacher who would challenge me in what I
am able to do in check who would you
know we would have conversations maybe
an hour or two a day and every time I
make a mistake the teacher he or she
pounces on me and tells me no that's
wrong and gives me examples or asks me
to come up with examples we record the
session I go home and I work very hard
on those areas where I'm making mistakes
these could be mistakes in terms of
patterns of the language in other words
the grammatical structure it could be in
terms of just choice of words that
that's not how people say the language I
that is something I would want to do in
six months so that I want the basics at
the end and now in Czech I've been at it
for over two months
I don't speak I don't write I have no
interest in doing that yet I'll wait to
do that I mean there's nothing wrong
with doing it I do record the odd thing
for my own use I have my little diary
that I started what I do is I write
stuff in English who will translate
translates it into Czech I look at it
tells me how I should have maybe said
that given that it's maybe thirty
percent wrong and then I record it for
fun it's kind of a record of my progress
in Czech probably in three or four
months and I also by the way take the
translation so I import these into into
link as my diary I also import the trans
the original English that I wrote and I
see how you know these increasingly I'll
be able to tell it the the resulting
check is a little bit strange but I
don't believe that it does me any harm
to to read or to record stuff that's
incorrect I don't think it does me any
harm even if I were to start speaking if
I were speaking to a native speaker who
couldn't correct me it wouldn't matter
to me because for most of the six months
I
getting my language my exposure to the
patterns and the words through listening
and reading so it's kind of like a
holistic whole language approach so I'm
doing the massive exposure to the
language first and then in six months
I'm gonna try to start speaking and then
I may start seeking before then but in
six months from now let's say I'm gonna
say okay deliberately now for two weeks
I want to be really corrected in
everything that I say and by that time
I'll have had enough exposure to the
language that those Corrections I think
will help me more where as Corrections
that I get at an early stage I think
from my own experience I don't remember
them it has a very little impact on me
so what I'm suggesting here and this is
what I'd like some ideas on we can
explore this back and forth is to turn
the thing upside down massive exposure
don't have to speak the whole language
take it in learn forget learn forget
struggle through stuff that's
interesting if you like doing graded
readers fine if you don't hit the more
you know difficult material and then at
the end go back and try to have an
intensive training in the basics and and
my own feeling is that I will get much
further that way than if I try to nail
down the basics through a sort of
traditional type of instruction you know
in the early stages that'll just delay
me because I won't have enough
familiarity exposure with the language
to take advantage of it and and I think
that that you know either my proposal
here is upside down or else traditional
language schools have it upside down in
other words it's possible and that's
where I want people's opinion it's
possible that that's the traditional way
of doing it which is you know call it a
Cartesian way you know an analytical
maybe that's the right way to do it I'm
saying no that the holistic way whole
language first I don't think that I will
accumulate bad habits just by listening
in other words I'm not speaking my you
know the amount that I will speak
incorrectly is minimal that will not
influence
I will not be in graining bad habits the
same with pronunciation if I don't
bother pronouncing I can start
pronouncing in six months at that time
they can nail me on my pronunciation and
work it hard but by that time I will
have had a lot of exposure to the
language so you know I don't think I'm
doing myself any harm by delaying that
sort of more you know teacher-centered
approach and so and I think that this
makes sense I think this is a better way
than what is as traditionally done and
I'm going to try to prove it with my
check but I'm also interested in hearing
the views of others here so thank you
for listening there's a few other things
that we're gonna say but I forget but if
there's interest they come back with
different things and I can perhaps to
hit this theme again in response to some
of the hopefully both the positive and
negative or you know contrary or
whatever opinions that I'll receive
thank you